and minimalists hello everybody welcome
to the minimalist podcast where we
discuss what it means to live a
meaningful life with less my name is
Joshua Fields Milburn and I'm Ryan
Nicodemus and together we are the
minimalist today we're gonna talk about
fear we're gonna talk about anxiety
we're gonna talk about worry and
discomfort and of course paranoia comes
along with it all well who better to
have in here to talk about paranoia than
someone who made an entire album about
paranoia a truly outstanding album by
the way leader wise is here we thank you
for being here yeah man I'm a I'm a fan
of your show oh and and I like how you
guys just get into stuff and you know
it's my it's my vibe for sure so well
you know we we're both big fans of your
music I didn't know a whole lot about
you until I started preparing for this
episode the only thing I knew is I feel
like you've made two classic albums and
I don't I don't use that word lightly
like I feel like you've made just I mean
you've made quite a few albums and I'm a
fan of your music but you have your
frames and then paranoia and we're here
today to celebrate a new EP that you
have castle's I just put out a new EP
castle's a week ago or so and yeah it's
it's each album is definitely a you know
I write different stages of your life
different things going on you want to
make different music I try not to get
too you know boring for myself no I try
to change it up as much as I can but
paranoia was definitely one of those
albums for me where I was in a different
place that I can say I was versus the
others it's probably the darkest album
I've made I mean even with the titles
like out of the gate but it was one of
those things I feel like I needed to do
I needed to make like that album in
order to kind of get to this one and I
always feel that way with the music I
feel like once I can get this chunk this
puzzle piece then I can go to the next
one you know and yeah paranoia was
interesting
you see it's dark but there are moments
of light lately I think that's the thing
with with hope and despair and we're
going to talk a bit about these topics
today with paranoia or maybe lesser
states of paranoia whether it's fear and
worry and we've got some questions from
our audience so I want to talk to you
more about
music let's dive into some of these
questions first Emily in Oklahoma City
has a question
hi this is Emily from Oklahoma City I
had a question surrounding the
relationship between physical
preferences and resilience my husband
has the mindset that continually
disregarding physical preference will
build strength and allows you the
ability to try physically under any
circumstance I was wondering do you
think these two are correlated and if so
where is the balance between challenging
yourself or putting yourself outside of
your comfort zone but also curating a
life that is cohesive with your
personality and allows you to thrive
Ryan I don't think I totally understand
the question here I think I well I mean
she's asking about physical preferences
versus resilience so when I heard this
question I thought about our trips to
the Russia bathhouse or Josh and I we go
to this place called voto Spa in West
Hollywood and like they have these crazy
hot saunas 220 degrees sometimes this
cold plunge that can get down to 30
degrees and it's super uncomfortable
I do not prefer to be in a 220 degrees
sauna I don't prefer to be in a 30
degree cold plunge however there are an
extreme amount of benefits to making
yourself uncomfortable in those rooms
and Josh can speak more to those and I
can't he's the scientist on the show
yeah there are a lot of benefits but the
benefits also come from the the there is
a lot of comfort that sort of surrounds
that as well right if we stay in a
perpetual state of discomfort that leads
to pain yeah if we are always
comfortable however that also leads to a
particular kind of pain now not only in
your and your music you you write a lot
about well pain and discomfort and and
these emotions that we experience maybe
we could talk a little bit about that
yeah I think I think there's you know to
what you were saying I think there's
also a difference between when you've
put yourself in those positions and when
those situations are out of your control
so I think like when it comes to
you know a lot of the music I write or
when I write about something painful or
you know for me personally it's a way
it's almost a therapeutic thing where I
can relive it but reliving it may sound
to the listener like wow are you okay
you okay sure we're for me I'm like huh
like it feels good so putting myself in
that place to to write that way but I
think a lot of the time speaking to fear
I think fear is one of those things that
it's when it's out of your control it
changes like who you are as a person you
know what I mean so for me I think that
a lot of the songs I write I'm just
trying to relate it back to my music
you're kind of put in a headspace where
you might act different than you would
normally under regular circumstances and
that's driven by the fear of whatever it
may be so for me I've had a life
especially last 15 years of putting
myself into very uncomfortable
situations you know starting with
American Idol is a is a perfect example
of that
before that I was never one to Hey look
at me or being a spotlight of any kind
it was uncomfortable for me the only
place it felt comfortable was when I was
on stage performing my own music that's
that was my comfort zone being on stage
being judged by people being on stage
being looked at by millions of people
that was very uncomfortable for me so as
much as I enjoyed getting up there and
performing the setting necessarily
wasn't the most inviting for me you know
right it also it was different because
you did you accepted it you you're the
one who signed up for it so to speak
where as opposed to if someone were to
drag you onstage when you weren't
prepared for it it would have been a
completely type of a completely
different type of discomfort yeah and I
think I think for some people it's the
opposite that limelight that thing is
where you know they they can embrace it
I think it just took me a long time to
really embrace that part of it what I
loved about it what I still love about
it is getting up playing my songs
telling a story through my music like
those things I love I love doing that
but early on especially when I was
younger you know
it was the it was the fear of the of not
knowing what was going to happen next
that was really keeping me in it I think
the opposite is also true that there is
a certain kind of complacency that comes
from comfort when Ryan and I were back
in the corporate world in fact there
were certain aspects of luxury or
comfort we made really good money in the
corporate world we had supposedly
prestigious job titles and I never had
like this really outstanding life but it
was comfortable enough that I was afraid
to make a change because I knew that
when I made a change there would be some
sort of pain associated with them oh my
god I have to walk away from this really
good salary or these the the benefits or
the supposed job security I realized
later there's actually no such thing as
his job security but at the in the
moment it felt it felt real but Ryan if
we could return back to Emily for a
second I think both things can be true
and I think you actually need her
husband is maybe radically embracing the
discomfort and the letting go and and a
sort of Spartan approach toward toward
living and I think there are there are
times for that however letting go just
for the sake of letting go is also not
necessarily beneficial yeah I mean I
think you hit the nail on the head
earlier when you said if you're making
yourself uncomfortable to a point of
pain and I think that is the key
different difference between you know
the preferences versus resilience is are
you doing something that's making you
uncomfortable to make you to grow
because I'm sure it's a lot easier to
not write music and to not get on stage
yeah I mean there are times where you to
get inspired to be totally honest when
you're and I think this cross crosses
all things I think whether it be art
media any kind of art form I think it
you have to kind of sometimes put
yourself in a position where you might
not be comfortable because that's where
you'll get some of your best stuff you
know writing I mean I I lean off have a
song on paranoia called let go and that
song for me you know is
wasn't an easy song to write like
emotionally you know it's not like
something I sat down and said this is
fun
and it was really but once I once for me
when it comes to writing once I dive
into it and I can I'll never take it to
a point where it's it so it's sad you
know there's those moments of sadness
and and I really can draw from that it's
actually beneficial for me in that way
where I can do some of my best writing
that way you know lots of times people
have asked me especially with this for
that album in particular you know your
song seems so sad I and I'm you know I
don't tend to write songs when I'm
walking around happy and like you know
like I'm gonna write a song that's not
usually my thing so for me I think
putting myself in that position to be
uncomfortable to live through some of
those pains is important for an artist
if I think because that's where you can
kind of draw some of your most emotional
honest work you know I think people can
connect with something when it's honest
and I think I think that pain in in in
those kind of things or things everyone
has experienced in some way or another I
almost feel like there's a connection
you get with somebody when they're when
they feel that you've had that same pain
you know I think lots of times with pain
and fear and all of those things you
tends to make you feel alone sometimes
and I think when people can feel like
you've experienced it as well there's
almost this connection they feel with
you I think musics a really good vehicle
to like bridge that between like people
and and and those kind of emotions and I
think that's why you know my music may
resonate with people it's what resonates
with me men like I yeah I really enjoy
it so Josh you mentioned the fear of
leaving your job you weren't scared of
the pain you were scared of the
discomfort and the comfort prevented you
from taking a risk to experience that
discomfort yeah ultimately I mean
initially I was scared of pain because I
never really stopped to to question
you've got that line in paranoia another
bad line of questioning right lay and
that's the thing that really leads to
these the the fear and what I perceive
to be pain right because I thought like
well if I leave here then of course all
of the worst things that could ever
happen are certainly going to happen and
I didn't even stop to actually ask
better questions
and that's the paranoia aspect of it
right I think fear like fears so you
have those fears and that that you can
almost make sense of it like I'm afraid
because this might happen but it's once
the fear kind of takes over that's when
the paranoia starts to set in and now
all of a sudden that's when the
irrational stuff starts to set in and
and you know you might be afraid like
let's say to leave your job but in that
moment it's just I'm afraid to leave my
job because then what'll I do but then
it's well then this will happen and this
will happen and you have all these
things and it kind of takes up a lot of
your headspace and we're all the same
this is the worst thing that can happen
but we are not asking ourselves like
what is the best thing that can happen
and in some cases like the worst thing
can happen is really bad what's the
worst thing to happen if I jump out of
this airplane well I might die so what
should I do maybe I should have a
parachute a backup parachute you plan
for jumping out of this airplane instead
of just I'm gonna jump out right and but
what's the the best thing that can
happen in some instances you know man
maybe I could start my own business I
can finally write that book I want to
write it there are a lot of things I can
do and often what's the worst thing that
can happen nothing at all it's fake
fears it's what our friend Julian Smith
calls the flinch
we used to flinch because you know a
tiger was chasing us and now we flinch
because oh no my 401 K lost one tenth of
a percent last week and and we're
panicked about it and that leads to that
the paranoia that you're talking about
and so many of these fears are actually
irrational fears and occasionally there
might be a rational fear and then that's
a sign to maybe avoid that thing right
yeah I think there's the control of it
is another thing again putting yourself
in a position where you have to face
something that you're afraid of versus
being forced into a position where
you're you've to deal with something
you're afraid of is there very different
for me you know if I'm gonna make a
decision okay this is scary I'm gonna do
this thing but okay it's I'm afraid of
it but I'm gonna like face it versus
saying now you're in this position and
you don't want to be here and I think
the fear can kind of guide how you
handle that situation you know what I
mean ya know that that actually makes a
lot of sense man going back to the
airplane thing you're scared to jump out
of an airplane but if you got a
parachute you're a little less scared
you got a backup parachute you're a
little less scared if you have someone
you're jumping tandem with you're a
little less scared but that fear should
be an indication of
everyone pushes you out right well
here's here's like here's the like a
short answer I would give Emily here is
it's a it's okay to make yourself
uncomfortable like from-from discomfort
is where growth happens it is not okay
to continue continually put yourself in
a painful situation that eventually is
going to it's going to lead to negative
consequences yeah yeah if you're if you
are not careful with something for long
enough it breaks and I think we need to
be we need to be careful of that as well
so yeah putting yourself in these
moments of discomfort but in a sort of
careful way yeah is sounds like where
you're going Emily I'm gonna send you a
copy of our book everything that remains
it's really the story of us going
through a whole lot of discomfort
leaving the corporate world but much
more than that walking away from a
discontent a discontented life that was
no longer bringing us joy or happiness
or in fact it was leading to this sort
of paranoia in a way like clinging yeah
so hard that it was impossible to let go
and really this five year journey of
being the suit-and-tie corporate guys to
become in the minimalists and I think
you'll find a lot of value in that book
Sean if you would send her maybe the
audiobook version if you like our
podcast you'll like the audiobook or if
you want the book book or the e-book
we're happy to send those to you as well
Nicole from East Chester New York has a
question hi this is Nicole yeah though I
am from East Chester New York a big
thank you for all your podcasts as you
help me to downsize my career as an
assistant principal back to a teacher
and although I took a tremendous pay cut
I'm gaining a huge amount of time back
in my life to spend with my two young
children which is something that I
desperately needed my question is since
I stayed in my same industry and
actually in my same school district how
do you deal with people thinking you're
absolutely crazy and insane for taking
such a huge step backward without
getting into a whole long story of your
love affair my love affair with
minimalism and simple with it
all right so I'm gonna read this thing
from Seth Godin real quick because it
stood out to me and then I know Lee has
had a few things to say about this as
well this is called offstage I wonder
what Carole King is up to did that kid
who was in your third grade class ten
years ago get in to his first choice of
college how did that couple that had a
squabble in your in your store last week
settle their argument we don't notice
people when they're not in front of us
of the tens of thousands of people
familiar and famous that we know we
spend precious little time concerned
about the ins and outs of their day and
more poignant Lee the same is true for
the way the world ignores our day-to-day
lives as well humans selfish survival
instinct is to be aware of whoever is on
stage in front of us and then to move on
to the next urgency I won't read the
entire thing we'll put a link to that in
the show notes but I think one thing
that that Nicole needs to think about
here is most people don't actually care
that's why I bring that out like we
often think like so many people were
concerned about me what'd she say taking
a step back but I think most of the time
especially when you're not there in
front of them most people don't really
care it's just the the pressure that
we've conceived is also self conception
and once we realize that we can realize
that maybe 98 percent of the the sort of
judgment that we're feeling is us
judging ourselves to a great extent yeah
I think also it comes down to what
people on the outside may perceive as
like success or what a step forward
would be you know someone may look at
someone that's you know an actor or a
musician and say you know why are they
doing that that's a step back but I
think that a step back for someone on my
for themself might be a step forward
someone on the outside is looking at it
as a step backwards and I think it's
very easy to let those outside
influences affect what you're doing
where you may say I'm gonna do this
thing and it may you know may be
different for me my
out of my comfort zone and then if you
listen to those kind of outside voices
if you listen to that thing there is an
element of understanding why someone
might say that you know okay so you
looking at it from a different angle I
guess but for me at least the way I've
always tried to do things is you know I
have a goal in mind
and if that goal means I have to take
this take a little bit of a different
route this way or that way that's fine
and you everyone I mean coming from the
spot I've been and I've been I've seen
all I've seen all aspects of it from
every side and what you're saying is
very true most people don't care do you
know what I mean and and I think a lot
of its in your head and I think if you
just kind of have a goal in mind how you
get there you know that's up to you but
you can't listen to the outside I mean
she's talking a lot about people telling
me I'm taking a step back I to me that's
it's almost like irrelevant there's a
reason it's relevant for her though
because these are people that she cares
about or respects she works with in some
extent yes she's for spend time with
them but also realizing that the
direction they're headed in may not
necessarily be the direction you're
headed in and also the things that make
them happy or pleased or satisfied or
fulfilled are not going to be the same
things that make you happy satisfied
pleased or fulfilled and in fact the
things that make them contented with
their life may actually get in the way
of your own contentment because their
recipe is so radically different from
yours
and it's the same thing with food if you
enjoy a particular food and someone else
doesn't enjoy it then what you're not
supposed to enjoy it now yeah I wonder
how many people are actually coming to
Nicole and saying you've took you've
taken a step backwards you're crazy
I wonder if it's if this is more of an
internal thing that's going on I mean
and I would say like if there are people
legitimately coming to her and they're
saying Nicole what is wrong with you
you've taken a step back you've taken a
huge pay cut
I mean first and foremost honestly I
don't think she should care what other
people think but I understand she works
with them I understand that maybe it's a
loved one or friends absolutely so so my
first piece of advice is Nicole
I wouldn't I wouldn't pay attention to
your haters if you've got someone who
genuinely is concerned about you then
you can very genuine you can very
genuinely explain how you got your time
back and now you're able to spend time
with your kids
and the pay decrease that you took the
position the lower position that you
took was much more worth that that
opportunity cost was worth having more
time for your family and for your kids
if you're still you know paying the
bills and you're getting by in life then
it's okay to be content with that
unfortunately there are people out there
though who aren't going to support you
and even if you say oh I you know I did
it for my kids and they might push back
and be like oh well you know if you
really cared about you kids you'd make
more money and you know be able to send
them to a better college I'm just saying
there are people out there like that
like what you read you were talking
about day to day like what people don't
know the ins and outs in the day to day
to what everything is you know I think
people on the outside have a tendency no
matter what you do like someone might
say to you guys with a podcast yeah you
just go in a room and you do interviews
right like they don't understand
the levels and the things you have to do
in order just to do certain things for
me music you know I mean the amount of
times people come up to me said why
aren't you why haven't you it's just I
think that there is an element of you
know the person that understands your
life the best is you and and and yes you
some people gonna make bad decisions
something we're gonna make better
decisions you know it's it's but there
is a learning process to life you know
it's not like it's just laid out like
here's what you do to get to where you
need to go to and so especially you know
again like for me I can only speak for
myself on this but for me I mean there's
been so many times where people have
questioned whether what I'm doing is the
right way of doing it or the wrong way
of doing it and for me and by the way
they're going to do that regardless of
what decision you make that they're
gonna be people say I can't believe you
went on American Idol and then there are
other people saying that was the best
decision you could have made right and
no matter what decision that you make
out of the infinite choices there's
always you can always find someone who
can criticize those and and that's
that's going to happen regardless the
the thing that I often you hear a site
in fact it's a line from one of our
books essential which I'm gonna send a
copy to Nicole it's sa collection with
150 different essays in it the line is
judgment is but a mirror that reflects
the insecurities of the person who's
doing the judging and ultimately if
someone's saying that is a bad decision
there's Henley that's a bad decision if
I were to make it for me right not
that's a bad decision for you or it's a
bad the shooters in for Ryan or for
podcast Sean or for Jordan no more over
here they're saying I'm projecting what
a bad decision is if I were to make that
if I were in your shoes yeah there's a
bottom line as well I think there's like
with around all the decisions you make
like for her it sounds like her kids
like that's her bottom I like as long as
I could take for me it's like the
songwriting that's my bottom line if if
if ended at the end of the day for me
what I try to make sure that is the
spine of everything I'm doing is that I
can keep the keep the songwriting at the
forefront of what I'm doing and making
sure it's honest to making sure it's the
kind of music that I want to be making
so there's like decisions around it but
for me like I I try to I always have
that to go back to do you know what I'm
saying so yes there might be a decision
to make here to say I don't know you
know it's it's it's you don't get to
know what's gonna happen but I think if
you kind of keep that core goal like
release for me
I feel as long as that's kind of at the
forefront of what I'm doing when I'm
when it comes to music I I feel good
about any decisions I'm making cuz
that's the base of what I'm I'm doing I
love it like Nicole what is your bottom
line like as long as you're aiming
towards that then yet no one should be
able to make you feel guilty about the
path that you've taken to to get to that
bottom line I I totally agree like you
mentioned earlier about the path you
might have to veer off a little bit
someone else is looking at like oles
veering off his path a little bit but
you're like no I'm actually getting
towards what I want to I want to get to
get to my bottom line yeah and once you
figure that out it helps you realize you
don't have to explain yourself to every
person in every decision that you make
you're not forced to explain yourself
and by the way the people who really
care about you they don't require an
explanation for every action that you
take especially if they feel good about
about you and
the decisions you make they may not
agree with oh my gosh can't believe you
took a step backward at work because
again that's their thought you simply
know that you took a step forward in
your life by simply changing your
position yeah I think if anyone wants to
get over criticism they should start a
blog write an album like get in the
public eye because you get so much
criticism when you put yourself in the
public eye like you you've got to get
used to it yeah you start developing
calluses and that's an interesting thing
because you know you've heard a lot of
people say you know if you're gonna be
in the public eye you're asking for it
right you're asking for it and I think
it's just something that come it does
come with the territory when you're in
the public eye of course people are
going to critique you and judge you and
look at what you're doing and and say
what they think they like and what they
don't like but I think an important part
is having people around that you that
you trust yeah and and trusting the
people that you put around you like
there's two pieces to that because for
me you know through my experience in my
you know path it really all could it's
so much easier to make what you make may
say are the right decisions or you know
feel good about what you're doing when
you have people around you that trust
you and then that you trust because I
think those are the people gonna be the
most honest with you
for instance person you know x over here
who might say I don't know if that's it
you know I I don't value it less but if
someone that I have a trust and a bond
with is like saying the same thing I
might look at it a little closer so I
just think that it's a way of keeping
yourself honest and keeping you you know
kind of your focus in line but I just
think that the kind of support team you
have around you that people you have
around you understanding your goals
understand what is that you want also
helps in the decision-making process
when it comes to certain things in your
career yeah or your life you know that's
why I got Josh in my life well I think
that's me know what I have crazy ideas
and we also provide solutions for each
other that's the difference between
criticism and feedback criticism
highlights a problem feedback highlights
a solution and my guess is if these
people accounted to Cole Nicole and
telling her I can't believe you did that
they're giving her criticism right
they're throwing problems her way
without a solution
in the it by the way is applicable to
her life and her circumstance Nicole
enjoy that copy of essential if you want
the audiobook it's our longest audiobook
I think it's over six hours or if you
want the book book or the e-book we'll
send you a copy of that as well Ryan
what time is it's time for our lightning
round where we answer questions from
social media indeed we do we are at the
minimalists on Twitter Instagram
Facebook lis your handles are different
on a few few platforms there yeah
because apparently when I check what I
tried to get my own name in certain
spots like that's already taken so I was
like okay fair enough so yeah it's
Twitter I think is at lead just at my
name at Lee DeWyze and Instagram is at
lead wise official there we go and his
website is Lee DeWyze official dot-com
as well they're in lightning round we
try to answer questions just short
shareable less than 140 character
response we put the text of these
minimal Maxim's in the show notes so you
can copy and share our pit the answers
on social media if you'd like and now
you can find all of our pithy answers in
one place minimal maxims dot-com all
right whatever really just ramble on a
little bit and then we squeeze out
something that makes it really nice and
posed all right first question is from
Nicolette I have a significant fear of
being alone or growing old and being
alone it terrifies me I'm mostly at home
but go out to run errands everyday I'm
currently going through a divorce which
is exacerbating the fear any advice to
call my intense fear I have a few pithy
answers but I really want to hear from
Lee on this one because you you write
about loneliness and being alone and and
that certainly makes it into into your
song so let's see real quick short
answer for me is comfort provides a
fertile environment for fear to grow
that's really the paranoia thing we were
talking about earlier because once you
are you you you reach a level of
certainty where your basic needs are met
but then you don't do anything to put
yourself in the discomfort zone you
don't do anything to grow you start to
develop these fears I'm gonna lose what
I have right and that so actually we're
we're Nicolette is right now is she's in
a place where there's a lot of things
are
what I'm trying to warn her against is
don't put yourself in in in a moment in
a lifetime of discomfort or of comfort
rather don't put yourself in a lifetime
of comfort going forward because you're
afraid of developing these these pains
of being alone and that means you're
gonna have to put yourself in some
uncomfortable situations where it means
going out and in meeting people because
I think I think a little discomfort is
sort of the antidote to fear to a great
extent not a tremendous amount you know
it's not like well I'm afraid to go
dancing well then I think you need to
you know needed to tango or you need to
join Dancing with the Stars or something
know it but but doing something that's
gonna make you a little bit
uncomfortable is actually going to be
the place that's going to it's going to
quash your fears and I also thought
about this tweet I sent out a few weeks
ago hate is just fear with things so
fear manifests in a bunch of different
ways sometimes will lash out at other
people you know I hate you or we see it
online all the time with Twitter and
Instagram people commenting on people's
stuff I think quite often we do that
we're I'll try to while other people up
or we troll other people out of our own
fear and insecurity to a great extent
now the I want to talk to you about I
want to talk about just this fear in
general but fear of of loneliness or
being alone I think a big part of
feeling alone that scares people is
having - isn't necessarily the fear of
not having someone there but it's you
know being with yourself 24/7 all the
time like I imagine being with someone
that you didn't like all day every day
every minute of every day by yourself
they would be the worst experience so I
think there's an element of like being
alone that's not so much a fear of not
having someone else but it's a fear of
having to live with just yourself and
and not having kind of a balance to that
and I think that at least for me that's
I've always kind of viewed it that way I
think some people love being alone some
some people you know
right that's majority of my house some
people love being alone and I think I
think some of one of the fears that
people have that sets in and being
honest once you're when you've not been
alone when you know what it's like to
not be alone and then now you're forced
to be in a position or you or you're in
a position where now you are alone and
it feels like something's missing when
in reality maybe something's not maybe
things are okay but you have this
feeling of like you were saying like
I've lost something and I want that back
and so the fear is you know it's kind of
it's a double-edged thing because you
want to go back out and fill that
missing piece but the last time you had
that piece it was painful and it was it
sucked but I think you know I think it's
there's an element of taking time to
reflect on yourself and kind of like you
know look at yourself when you have
those moments of alone and I think it'll
better your chances of getting over the
fear of being alone and finding maybe
someone else or whatever to fill that
void but you know for me I don't I don't
like I like being alone but then I
always think I like being alone and then
if I am I don't enjoy it at all because
I find that sometimes that's when my
brain starts it starts to turn and then
things you know and I think that's where
a lot of the fears can come in and a lot
of those things and I think when people
are afraid they tend they can't act
irrationally and like I said you'll make
decisions based on you know these these
false
paranoia's these these things that are
just aren't real and and so for me when
it comes to like loneliness and when I
write about it I guess I've always I'm
always having this internal conversation
with myself I find when I write it's
always this conversation I'm having with
me and and I don't know I've always
found loneliness to be one of those
things where you talk to some people and
they just love it you know I love being
alone that people I think people like to
say they like being alone and some
people really do but realistically I
think it's again just being stuck with
yourself all the time is is a hard thing
to do
yeah and so you're really opening my
mind up here because if we're not
comfortable with the if we don't like
the person that we spend the most time
with ourselves then it is going to be
very difficult to spend time with that
person alone I I have no problem I
really enjoy being alone I spend very
little time
family and I spend very little time with
other people I have a six-year-old
daughter and a wife but I still I've set
my life up so that I spend most of my
time alone I think it's because no one
likes me as much as I like me and I say
that jokingly but there is something to
be said I don't I didn't like my former
self I didn't like my my
twenty-something year old self very much
and so I compensated by having to spend
a lot of time with other people
co-workers networking buddies executives
people I didn't really share similar
values to but I was kind of afraid of
being with myself and having to confront
what's going on in here and up here and
and you're forced to deal with those
things when you're alone and we're
terrified of that silence and stillness
but once you start to deal with it
once you become the person that you want
to become or you get closer to that not
hard thing to do
yeah absolutely and it continues the it
continues to change ice I'm 38 years old
now I aspire to be my 40 year old self
right is a better version of me
hopefully and but before I aspired to be
a bunch of other people who weren't me
who didn't share my values but maybe
they had a shiny car or a fancy job
title but that wasn't me that was
someone else's sort of projection of
what I should be yeah it's funny man I
Josh has always went saw movies by
himself and I always thought that that
was like something that Psychopaths did
and we were living in Missoula Montana
and I was like why am i uncomfortable
with myself like this is really strange
that I can't go to a movie by myself so
I actually started going out and doing
things by myself to kind of face that
discomfort and I still am an extrovert
and love being around people but I can
totally be by myself and be okay there's
a balance there right like sometimes I
do need to be by myself most of the time
I need to be able someone else but
sometimes I do need to be by myself I
got a couple pithy answers here one is
giving into fear begets more fear so if
you let full fear rule your life then
you're gonna live a fearful life so
don't give in to it you consider it ask
yourself what that fear is doing but
letting it rule your life is it's not
going to be good the second one I have
is fears worst enemy is confidence
so Nicolette it sounds like maybe you're
lacking a little confidence in
developing these relationships I don't
see I don't know to the extent of is it
a agoraphobic is that yeah yeah so I
don't I don't know if she's like to that
extent an agoraphobic or if she's just
nervous about making new relationships
but what I'll say is if it is to a point
to a disorder you've got to go find
someone who can help you get over a
certain disorder if you're not in a
agoraphobic and you just don't know how
to go out and make new relationships
then you can do things like I go to
meetup.com there are a million different
groups with a million different
interests that you can kind of join and
go make some friends and go mingle but
in Infinite Jest David Foster Wallace's
novel there's a classroom where a
teacher is he he's really interested in
these double bonds so he's teaching a
class who are hypothetically agoraphobic
or their agoraphobe but they're also
kleptomaniacs
and so they have the impulse to get out
and steal steal steal but they can't
leave the house because they are
agoraphobic and how do you deal with a
double bond like this and one bright kid
figures out spoil earlier he figures out
mail fraud is a way that you can you can
take care of both fears here what are we
waiting mail fraud is what I'm
suggesting to you know also
understanding yourself we've talked
about that we have a values worksheet on
our website if you go to the minimalists
comm slash resources that should
actually be launched by the time this
podcast episode comes out there's a
values worksheet there you print it off
it's three pages it's gonna help you
better understand what your foundational
values are your structural values your
surface values and your imaginary values
are so you can get those obstacles out
of the way I think you'll enjoy that all
right before we get into our added value
segment and our listener tips today it
looks like we have a bunch more surprise
questions this week indeed we do what
are six tips for dealing with fear and
anxiety how can we lean into fear to
make ourselves more productive how
consumerism fed and increased fear and
paranoia in people today what do Joshua
and Ryan and Li personally fear is fear
and paranoia genetic how important is
developing emotional intelligence to
overcome fear and I think we have about
600,000 more questions for leader wise
and if you want to hear all that you can
listen to this week's maximal episode
available exclusively on patreon that's
right you're currently listening to our
weekly minimal episode but each week
Ryan and I and our guests record an
entirely different much longer maximal
episode on the minimalist private
podcast which gives us the private space
we need to talk about topics we don't
usually discuss in public plus patreon
is the best way for us to fund this
podcast and keep it 100% advertisement
free when we subscribe to the minimalist
private podcast on patreon you'll
receive a personal link so that our
maximal episodes play in your favorite
podcast app find all the details and all
the good stuff over at the minimalists
com a slash support Ryan what else you
got for us this week
Epstein didn't kill himself also here
are some voicemail comments and tips
from our listeners hi my name is Stefan
yeah I'm calling from st. Paul Minnesota
I'm calling with a suggestion for your
clothing episode I've been using these
socks called darn tough it's a company
from Vermont they guarantee their socks
for life I think all they sell is soft
actually and while they are a little bit
pricey they do go on sale and the
thought of having socks it will last
even my entire life or that will be
replaced by the company feels really
right like it's right up my alley
I've had these socks for over a year now
and they look as good as new I have had
to return one pair and the company had
excellent customer service so I highly
recommend them
hey Josh hey Ryan this is in response to
your podcast dealing with criticism
there's a quote that I found recently
that I've been implementing into my life
to really help me it goes as follows
treat everyone with politeness even
those who are rude to you not because
they are nice but because you are
alright y'all thanks again to Lee DeWyze
for joining us today please check out
his new EP it's called castles three
incredibly beautiful songs wherever you
get your music these days Apple Spotify
etc etc you can find it all there we'll
also put a link to his music in the show
notes if you can see him on tour please
do so he has an incredible live show Lee
DeWyze official com is his website and
real quick for right here right now
here's one thing that's going on in the
life of the minimalists ryan did you
know that scrolling is the new smoking
yeah dude all the cool people are doing
it well our good friend Dave over at
spire
they've created a bunch of different
wallpapers for us but one of the most
popular tweets of mine is scrolling as
the new smoking and I don't even know
what my most popular tweet is I'm not to
go through them and look I don't know I
just I asked Jessica she just tells me
like here's every website I can go to
and be like what is my most popular
tweet yes Ryan Nicodemus is most popular
tweets com
but no so scrolling is the new smoking
it's the sentiment that like we are we
are slowly damaging ourselves in some
way physically sometimes what do they
call that now with the the the social
media neck or or technology neck where a
lot of teens and gin Z folks are either
bending down so much it's like oh yeah
changing the bone structure so scrolling
is the new smoking and a beautiful
reminder is we now have a wallpaper for
your phone or for your desktop computer
or your laptop computer for your
computer it's just a reminder and Dave's
did a great job because the little
scroll on the side also looks like a
cigarette and so it's a beautiful
reminder that
hey it's okay to scroll occasionally but
when we are addicted to our devices it
is not healthy for us so if you want to
download that free wallpaper or any of
our other free wallpapers we have the
love people use things we have the
minimalist logo we have the minimalism
subtract logo we have five questions ask
before buying and we have several others
over at the minimalists comm slash
wallpapers including scrolling is the
new smoking if you have a question
comment or minimalism tip for our
podcast leave us a voicemail for zero
six two one nine seven eight three nine
or send a voice memo to podcast at the
minimalists comm you can comment on this
episode at youtube.com slash the
minimalists if you want our show notes
in your inbox sign up for our email list
over at the minimalists comm and you'll
also receive our simple Sunday emails
and for our added value this week we
should definitely play you out with well
it's the title track to leader wisest
album paranoia I really want to just
sing this myself he spared you Lee has
such a beautiful voice and what he did
with this song is it's amazing it's a
great song it's a perfect way to end an
episode about paranoia and let's play
about with that if you leave here today
with one message we hope it's this love
people and use things because the
opposite never works thanks for listen
y'all we'll see you next time
and minimus